welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
ending and post-credit scene of argyle
the Henry caval Bryce stallis Howard Sam
Rockwell spy movie directed by Matthew
vaugh with a big twist or really a lot
of big twists and one of these twists
got accidentally spoiled when press
Outlets announced this movie 3 years ago
but a potentially even bigger twist in a
post-credit scene that realized what
this movie even is and if you saw the
movie you know what I'm talking about
but if you didn't see The Movie Spoiler
warning before I continue okay so Argyle
is a movie about Ellie Conway Bryce
Dallas Howard a shy spy novelist who
writes a series of7 style novels center
around the Spy character of Aubrey
Argyle Henry caval but she gets attacked
on a train by assassins from an
organization called The Division and
saved by another spy Aiden Sam Rockwell
who tells her that the division is after
her because her novels reflect real life
too coincidentally and could predict the
future so in what is presented as the
fictional spy world within this real
world Henry Cavo plays Argy dualipa
plays lrange and John Cena plays Wyatt
you know when you watch these brief
scenes I guess it kind of makes sense
because these three are bizarrely shaped
human beings who only exist in our
Collective imaginations anyway so while
Aiden is saving her on that train every
time Ellie blinks her perspective of
reality shifts so that she sees him as
Henry caval Argyle it starts to cluis in
that these fictional realities versus
her real reality might be one and the
same throughout the globe trotting
Adventure we learn from CIA deputy
director Alfred Solomon Samuel L Jackson
that Ellie's real name is Rachel Kyle k
y l l e or r
Kyle which is how she derived Argy she
was a former spy who was captured and
brainwashed by the division 5 years
prior and that she has been unknowingly
slipping her blacked out memories into
her writing and that is why she's such a
threat or really could say an asset to
the division so the premise of this
movie is basically what if Ian Fleming
who was the author of the James Bond
novels and actually served in the
British Naval intelligence during World
War II what if Ian Fleming continued to
work for British intelligence after the
war and then got captured by the enemy
and then got brainwashed so that he
didn't remember his past as a government
agent and then just started putting all
of his stories into the books he
published as if they were fictional
accounts and then like the KGB and the
CIA were like hey uh this James Bond guy
is a real guy we have to stop this
person and just so we're clear the real
Argyle of this movie is not Taylor Swift
even though social media sleuths were
pointing out that Swift had a
scottishfold cat and Ellie Conway has a
scottishfold cat which Matthew Von
admitted was inspired by Taylor Swift's
detective Olivia Benson and Dr meith
Gray okay so in the argyle movie Aiden
and Ellie Rachel go to Arabia to
retrieve a master key which is this
movies McGuffin that will expose the
division as a real life spy entity and
not just a fictional Spector type
organization from the books the division
captures them and its leader Ritter
played by Brian Cranston I'm telling you
this cast is stacked Ritter reveals that
Rachel was actually an asset reporting
to the division and then you know
there's some classic spycraft shift and
loyalty twisty stuff but then we learn
that Rachel's mother Ruth Katherine
O'Hara was actually another duplicitous
spy and uses a murrian candidate style
trigger Cod code to flip Rachel against
Aiden but you know it all works out and
Alfred Solomon receives Rachel's message
with the master key but the movie ends
with Rachel returning to her life as a
novelist promoting her final novel at a
book event where what the real Argyle
Henry caval reveals himself to her he is
a real person in this world and to make
matters even more confusing in a
post-edit scene we find ourselves 20
years earlier in a pub called The King's
man with the kingsman symbol on a banner
hanging from the post in front of it
this is a symbol associated with the
kingsman organization from Matthew Von's
kingsman the Secret Service film series
and we see a young man played by LS
Partridge approaching the bartender he
asks for a Cosmopolitan with a Twist the
bartender says does it look like we're
in a club or a pub and this young man
says hold the Vodka the cintro the
cranberry juice just a Twist and the
bartender says coming right up and he
hands him a box and the bartender says
You must be in a lot of trouble if they
sent you to me darling and the young man
opens the box he says that is a Twist
partner asks what's your name and the
Young man says Aubrey Aubrey Argyle so
this is a young version of Henry Cav's
Argyle and the text appears on screen
Argyle book one the movie coming soon so
when Matthew vongh screened this movie
for critics they immediately asked if
the kingsman Pub was meant to place
Argyle in the same universe as Von's
Kingsman film series and Von told
polygon well they both exist in my head
so that is the Universe I will say that
Argyle wears very well cut suits that's
all I'll say for the time being and v in
October told happy sad confused podcast
there is a universe and what we're
trying to do with Marv that's Von's
production company Marv is sort of you
know marvel to superheroes We want to be
despised as well so we've got the
kingsman on the right I'd say our girls
on the left and then we've got an idea
for something in the middle as well and
then you've got these these sort of
competing franchises in a galaxy that
one day might meet so this argal film is
revealed to be part of the continuity of
Matthew Von's Kingsman series which
includes 2014 kingsman the Secret
Service starring Taran ederton and Colin
fth as well as the 2017 sequel kingsman
the Golden Circle and the 2021 prequel
the king's man which is set during World
War I and establishes the birth of the
Kings man organization setting it within
this alternate history of early 20th
century European leaders so just a
reminder that the kingsman service is a
top secret spy Organization for the
British government with operatives who
derive their codeen names from Arthurian
Legend like all the agents have codeen
names based on the Knights of the Round
Table you got lelot you got Galahad and
they're supported by a q type character
Coden named Merlin they operate out of
facilities disguised as high-end tailor
shops they wear bulletproof suits and
have high-tech glasses in 2017 after the
Golden Circle came out Von announced
another sequel the third of this run
that would be called kingsman the blue
blood for which he wanted Dwayne Johnson
as The Villain but that has yet to go
into production we don't really know the
status of it right now but I am now
wondering if this movie's final twist is
meant to set up Henry caval to be the
protagonist of kingsman the blue blood
which would be hilarious because after
Dwayne Johnson promised to Showdown with
Henry caval at the post credit scene of
Black Adam who knows we may get that
here just in a different Cinematic
Universe in 2018 Matthew Von said that
he was developing an 8 episode TV series
called Statesmen which would follow the
American branch of the kingsman
organization that was introduced in the
2017 Golden Circle film initially Von
said that channy Tatum Jeff Bridges and
Halle Berry would all reprise their
roles but last we heard in December 2021
Von said that the project was being
redeveloped as a series but you know
it's just kind of been a minute since
we've heard anything on that last
October just a couple months ago it was
reported that the king's man prequel
would get a follow-up film that would be
set in this alternate history 20th
century timeline called The King's man
the traitor King and this would follow
the fictionalized rise of Adolf Hitler
played by David Cross in which Hitler
would come to power and basically was
supported by the English aristocracy so
the king's man the traiter king would be
set like in the 193s in between the wars
and I find it fascinating that Von
script would explore the way even the
British royal family supported the Nazis
and speaking specifically of king Edward
VII he was a documented Nazi sympathizer
and had he not abdicated historians
would have wondered wondered what would
happen in World War II like is this
movie going to show how this service
forced him to abdicate so yes the
traitor King probably refers to King
Edward VII and at New York ComiCon last
October when Von talked about this he
said that the script for this movie was
complete if you're looking for an easy
way to pamper yourself revamping your
daily hygiene routine is a great place
to start and geology is here to help
geology is a 29 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health opr daily hype Beast birdie
Esquire and GQ geology products used
just a handful of powerful proven
ingredients that have been trusted by
dermatologists for decades geology can
help you fight acne reduce oiless
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother or hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging you don't
know where to start geology can create a
simple and effective skincare or hair
care routine for you all you got to do
is take a quick 30 second quiz right now
if you use code new rockstars 100
geology will give you 100% off their
award-winning skincare trial set you'll
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30% off one skin hair or body product
when you add it to your trial so 100%
off plus an additional 30% off hope you
save some champagne because this is a
deal we're celebrating click the link in
the description or go to GE log. i/
Rockstar 100 to get started so I find
this whole Twist of the argyle film to
be pretty interesting because it reminds
us that other cinematic universes
outside the MCU DC Star Wars and the
monster verse actually do exist remember
Mite Shyamalan tried to pull a similar
move at the end into the 2017 movie
Split that revealed that movie which we
all thought was just a James maoy
psychological horror film to actually be
a surprise sequel to his 2000 movie
Unbreakable setting up this other inite
Shyamalan superhero universe that ended
in the 2019 movie glass and that was not
good and I love to point out that Samuel
L Jackson was also the connective tissue
of that continuity and after Marvel
Studios used Jackson to establish the
MCU in the Iron Man post credit scene I
just think Samu Jackson gets a kick out
of being this guy in every Cinematic
Universe however there is some overlap
with Samu Jackson playing the deputy CIA
director Alfred Solomon and Argyle
because he also played the Evil Tech
entrepreneur Richmond Valentine in the
2014 Kingsman Secret Service movie are
they the same character no I don't think
so because Jackson obviously doesn't
have the obnoxious lithp in this movie
but I'm sure people are going to spin
these fan theories that say that
Richmond Valentine acquired that
obviously fake lithp as a cover but it
just doesn't make sense because
Valentine was such a public figure and
he would just have to do all kinds of
logical gymnastics with timelines to
conclude that they could be the same guy
so my verdict is they're not hey say
what you will about Matthew Von he has
such an over-the-top style and a love of
60s aesthetic that the fact that these
movies are linked this way actually kind
of makes sense it reminds me of that
meta theory that all of Quinton
Tarantino's movies exist in a shared
Universe from the detail of the Vega
Brothers the Apple cigarettes and the
idea that since the Eng glorious
bastards ended World War II the way that
they did that would result in this
alternate history where Western Society
evolved to be obsessed with Cinema and
Ultraviolence which would have even
butterfly affected the man family
murders in 1969 a history that Tarantino
also Alters in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I think that might be what
Matthew vaugh is trying to do with his
Kingsman series plus Argyle because
Argyle could be a kind of metatextual
narrative that uses an in Universe
medium spy novels as a reflection of a
real stylized alternate history that
these characters have lived through one
that might have been affected by World
War I and World War II history just
going slightly different just having a
slightly altered vent to them now I
guess you could also interpret those
stories as like a future book series
that Ellie writes or maybe those could
just be simply characters within an in
Universe Miller World comic series
because those comics in our world is
what all of this is based on and maybe
in the Cinematic Universe exi and
Galahad in the kingsman service could
just be based on Ellie's stories and
that could be why the deputy CIA
director just kind of looks like the
past villainous Tech entrepreneur it
could also retcon that crass joke that
ended the 2014 movie as just a
regrettable throwaway joke written by
novelist Ellie Conway but I'm sure
Matthew Von would would get even more
backlash for reassigning that joke to
the idea of a female character that he
created and would now be using as a
shield now remember the name Argyle
comes from R Kyle but the fact that
Argyle with one L refers to a pattern
you would find in a tailor shop I just
can't help but wonder if he derived that
code name from the tailer shop World Of
The Kingsmen shifting to the code name
of argyle away from being so monarchal
because think about it will this service
be as cool in the present day as it's
bending the knee to King Charles or King
William I don't know about you I kind of
felt gross watching the final season of
the crown as it steered into a cutesy
romcom for William and K I don't know I
just think we all prefer to mythologize
the British crown as something in the
past something old and honestly kind of
seems like Matthew VOD agrees with that
because he is focusing his prequel
sequel on the Crown's past associations
with Nazi sympathizing through Edward
VII so Von is firmly establishing
himself as less of an Ardent loyalist
than like Peter Morgan is as the
executive producer of the crown but also
we just kind of have to see how all this
goes because while the 2014 and 2017
movies were pretty successful the king's
man was kind of a flop and I don't know
how successful Argyle is going to be so
I want to hear your thoughts on Argyle
it's crazy ending in this Kingsman
Cinematic Universe that we might never
get hit me up in the comments below
subscribe to new rock stars and you can
follow me at eaos thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye
a